Until about the 1970s, doctors used to inject
potentially pregnant women’s urine inside
female rabbits, and the rabbits would then
be killed to examine their ovaries and tell
if the woman was pregnant.
What?!
Hello there children of pregnancy, Jules here
for DNews!
In 2008, Thomas Beatie, a man, gave birth,
not via c-section, to a healthy baby girl.
His pregnancy was a pretty big deal; he was
on Oprah, became a public speaker, and later
gave birth to two more children.
Beatie is one of a number of transgender men
who have elected to have a child.
In 2014 in Australia alone, which is one of
the few countries to track such statistics,
Medicare reported 54 men who had given birth,
based on the gender noted in their medical
documentation.
But one of the many non-heartwarming reactions
to the Beatie story was that his pregnancy
did not “count”, because he was designated
female at birth and had a uterus, or a…
duderus.
Thankfully, these inexplicably angry detractors,
are likely not medically trained professionals,
or they’d know that a uterus is by no means
necessary for forming babby.
In fact, every one-in-ten thousand pregnancies
ends up with the fetus coming to term in the
abdomen, specifically the peritoneal (parrot-toe-neal)
cavity.
This can happen when, after conception, the
egg moves towards the uterus but falls out
of the fallopian tube into the abdomen.
There have even been cases of simultaneous
uterine AND abdominal pregnancies, which makes
the kids more like neighbors than womb-mates.
Any pregnancy where the fetus develops outside
the uterus is known as “ectopic”, and
serves as a useful model for what happens
to babies born outside of standard conditions,
say, within a man’s abdomen.
One fascinating take away is that these abdominal
pregnancies are more likely to result in a
female birth than a male one, by a ratio of
roughly 2 to 3.
Turns out, male fetuses are much worse at
surviving an uncomfortable gestation environment,
although for both sexes, abdominal pregnancies
very rarely produce a live birth.
Nonetheless, the fact that fetuses can develop
outside of the uterus has raised serious questions
about whether it would be possible for men
to have such an ectopic implantation.
And, it’s a tricky subject.
On the one hand, a number of doctors say that
such an pregnancy would be completely possible:
the embryo would be implanted in the abdomen,
the placenta would attach to abdominal organs,
and delivery would be done by C-section.
Any missing pregnancy hormones could be supplemented
with injections.
But despite the theoretical capability, no
man, or woman, or any person, has yet to go
through with such an implantation, mainly
because, on its face, it is an incredibly
dangerous procedure.
One bioethicist explained that the question
wasn’t “Can a man do it”, but “Can
he survive it?”.
So for humans, the answer is pretty decidedly
“Yes, but in some cases, it might kill you.”
But forget about humans for a second… what
about seahorses?
Great question.
Seahorses are a member of the Syngnathidae
(sig-natha-die) fish family, most of which
display a fascinatingly unique form of pregnancy.
Male seahorses have a special pouch, or what
we can call a “womb”, on the front side
of their tails.
When male and female seahorses mate, the female
deposits her eggs into the male’s pouch,
where they gestate for roughly one to six
weeks before the male “gives birth” to
a bunch of tiny seaponies.
Just kidding, they’re still called seahorses,
and the baby ones are called “Frys”, and
also ponies aren’t baby horses anyway, a
pony is just a type of horse.
The more you know!
So, can men get pregnant?
Hell yes, they totally can, and some even
have.
But most don’t, since in most cases it’s
super dangerous, and it’s hard to see a
reason to do so unless you’re a bodybuilder
doctor trying to prove the effectiveness of
fertility drugs that the FDA won’t let you
test on women, so Danny DeVito convinces you
to test it out on yourself, and later you
become the Governor of California.
So men can get pregnant but do we really even
need women's eggs to get pregnant?
Can we just do it with sperm and like a toe
nail?
Maybe!
Find out
in this video.
So how do you think the world would be different
if men got pregnant on a regular basis?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe for more
DNews every single day.